EXPLODED INTO THE CAPITOL
INSURRECTION.
A LOT MORE TO COME ON THAT IN
JUST A MOMENT SO MAKE SURE YOU
STAY TUNED.
MEANWHILE THERE IS THIS
CRISIS -- THIS ONGOING CRISIS ON
THE BORDER.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION RAMPING
UP DEPORTATIONS AS HEAVY
MACHINERY AND DUMP TRUCKS CLEAR
OUT THE MAKESHIFT MIGRANT CAMP
IN DEL RIO, TEXAS.
THE SCENES THERE ARE REALLY
HORRIFIC.
THEY ARE HARD TO WATCH.
AND THEN TRUE TO DISGUSTING
FORM, OVER AT THE PROPAGANDA
NETWORK, THE FOX PROPAGANDA
NETWORK TUCKER CARLSON CYNICALLY
USING WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER TO STOKE WHITE
NATIONALISM, PUSH THE BOGUS
GREAT REPLACEMENT THEORY THAT
FALSELY CLAIMS THAT WHITE
AMERICANS ARE BEING
INTENTIONALLY REPLACED BY BLACK
AND BROWN MIGRANTS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT FEAR.
IT'S ABOUT RILING UP HIS
VIEWERS.
IT'S ABOUT PROFITING OFF OF THE
VERY HUMAN TRAGEDY HAPPENING AT
THE BORDER.
>> HERE'S BIDEN EXPLAINING THE
ENTIRE POINT OF MASS IMMIGRATION
BACK IN 2015 WHEN HE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> AN UNRELENTING STREAM OF
IMMIGRATION, NONSTOP, NONSTOP.
FOLKS LIKE ME WHO WERE OF
CAUCASIAN AND EUROPEAN DESCENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 2017 WE'LL
BE AN ABSOLUTE MINORITY IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
ABSOLUTE MINORITY.
FEWER THAN 50% OF THE PEOPLE IN
AMERICA FROM THEN AND ON WILL BE
WHITE EUROPEAN STOCK.
THAT'S NOT A BAD THING.
THAT'S A SOURCE OF OUR STRENGTH.
>> AN UNRELENTING STREAM OF
IMMIGRATION, BUT WHY?
WELL, JOE BIDEN JUST SAID IT.
TO CHANGE THE RACIAL MIX OF THE
COUNTRY.
THAT'S THE REASON.
>> OKAY, LISTEN.
YOU CAN TAKE ANY SOUND BITE AND
MIP IT, OKAY.
SO LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT THERE.
LET'S STOP RIGHT THERE.
I KNOW THAT YOU WILL BE SHOCKED
TO HEAR THAT HE IS
MISREPRESENTING WHAT JOE BIDEN
SAID, RIGHT?
THAT'S WHEN HE WAS THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
THE REFERENCE TO AN UNRELENTING
STREAM OF IMMIGRATION, THE THEN
VICE PRESIDENT WAS TALKING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION THROUGHOUT AMERICA'S
HISTORY STARTING IN THE 1700s IF
YOU LISTEN TO THE ENTIRE THING.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO WHAT HE
ACTUALLY SAID.
>> WE ARE A MELTING POT.
IT IS THE ULTIMATE SOURCE OF OUR
STRENGTH.
IT IS THE ULTIMATE SOURCE OF WHO
WE ARE, WHAT WE BECOME.
AND IT STARTED ALL THE WAY BACK
IN THE LATE 1700s.
THERE HAS BEEN A CONSTANT
UNRELENTING STREAM OF
IMMIGRATION.
>> SO THAT SPEECH WAS ABOUT
CELEBRATING OUR IMMIGRATION --
CELEBRATING IMMIGRATION AND HOW
IT MAKES AMERICA STRONGER.
BUT TUCKER CARLSON, HE WANTS YOU
TO BE AFRAID OF IMMIGRANTS.
HE WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE THEY ARE
PART OF A NEFARIOUS PLOT TO
REPLACE WHAT HE EMPHATICALLY
CALLS LEGACY AMERICANS -- I
WONDER WHAT YOU MEANS BY THAT --
WITH FOREIGNERS.
>> JOE BIDEN JUST SAID IT, TO
CHANGE THE RACIAL MIX OF THE
COUNTRY, TO REDUCE THE POLITICAL
POWER OF PEOPLES WHOSE ANCESTORS
WHO LIVED HERE.
IN POLITICAL TERMS THIS POLICY
IS CALLED THE GREAT REPLACEMENT
WITH MORE OBEAD I WANT PEOPLE
FROM FAR AWAY COUNTRIES.
>> OKAY, LISTEN, WHEN YOU DON'T
SEE PEOPLE FOR WHO THEY ARE,
PEOPLE, FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS
RISKING THEIR LIVES FOR A BETTER
LIFE FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES, THAT'S WHAT YOU GET.
SO, YES, DO WE HAVE PROBLEMS AT
THE BORDER, YES.
THE PEOPLE ARE HUMAN BEINGS
TRYING TO GET HERE FOR A BETTER
LIFE.
THERE SHOULD BE A HUMANE WAY TO
DO IT, AND THERE SHOULD BE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE THE
REASON THEY'RE COMING IS FOR THE
RIGHT REASONS, WHAT THEY SAY.
BUT I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO ONE
OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO WAS DEPORTED
BACK TO HAITI TELLING HIS STORY.
>> WHEN WE ARRIVED IN THE U.S.,
THE AUTHORITIES PUT US ON A BUS
AND SENT US TO JAIL AND SAID WE
WOULD BE RELEASED IN TWO DAYS.
THEY PUT CHAINS ON OUR FEET,
AROUND OUR STOMACHS AND OUR
HANDS.
THEY PUT US IN CARS AND TOOK US
TO THE AIRPORT.
THERE WERE HAITIANS WORKING ON
THE PLANE WHO TOLD US NOT TO
RESIST BECAUSE THERE WERE MANY
SOLDIERS ON THE PLANE, AND THEY
WARNED US THAT OTHERWISE WE
WOULD BE MISTREATED.
>> SO HERE'S WHAT I'LL SAY.
YOU CAN RANT AND RAVE ON YOUR
WHITE POWER HOURS ABOUT
REPLACEMENT THEORY, TURNING A
CRISIS INTO A PROPAGANDA,
STOKING RACISM.
THAT'S YOUR THING.
BUT IT DOES NOTHING, NOT A
SINGLE THING TO HELP SOLVE ANY
OF THE VERY REAL PROBLEMS AT THE
BORDER, AND IT HURTS AMERICA.
WE NEED TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS